good day everyone
I'm your host monster Maze and today I
am here with Conrad as you can see on
screen uh he's one of the lucky few who
got to play Tears of the Kingdom or at
least the demo
um so right up front I'm gonna have to
set some rules real quick uh because
this is not like the usual situation
where there's just a trailer and we can
all just freely discuss uh there is an
embargo going on so
both Conrad and Celtic the ones who got
to play the game they do have to abide
by certain rules there's some certain
things they cannot talk about
um there I will be showing his video
this is basically just directly from his
upload to his channel and I also have
the footage uh from Celtic who also gave
me permission to show footage so I will
just be
showing that footage in the background I
might be sifting through it once in a
while and
um we'll just start discussing so first
of all Conrad how how was it how was the
experience
well this game is something else uh I
don't think any game has ever been this
interactive given so many tools and
possibilities uh to engineer experiment
uh as this like in breath of all you you
were doing physics experiments but here
you're going The Next Step you're
literally going from the science
laboratory in your uh what's the
elementary school to University level uh
uh Post University level engineering you
can build cars you can build uh planes
you can build all kinds of stuff uh with
the different zono tools uh at least the
ones I can talk about yeah yeah well
there seems to have been a very clear
focus in this uh gameplay like this demo
was seems to have been catered towards
experimentation with the Zone technology
mostly uh because
from what I've seen you were not allowed
to explore much
because they didn't want you to find too
many things like on the surface and uh
they they wanted to keep it confined
right
yeah the best way I would compare this
to is uh theme park rides uh where you
can of course go outside the area but uh
the people uh watching you are not going
to be very happy about it and we were
watched by a representative uh from
Nintendo I think there was also one from
Japan there that oversaw the whole group
to make sure that there was no mess
because it's glad that this lazim is not
fooling around uh with uh tears of the
Kingdom we have seen some not being able
to uphold the strict rules of the
Embargo uh well of course it's it's
probably mistakes but some of the stuff
is just it's just sloppy sloppy work
especially by big Outlet I'm not going
to mention names but you probably know
who it is yeah well that that's also one
thing uh obviously people are gonna ask
questions we have one for example from
Isaac thank you by the way for the Super
Chat he says did you try Shield surfing
with the rocket Shield
oh uh actually that was not a
possibility mainly because we didn't
have rails uh to ride on uh and also the
sky islands we visited were flat they
were like really they were not much of
an opportunity to uh try to shred
well obviously we know that Shield
surfing is still in the game and it's
actually been expanded to grinding on on
Rails and stuff like that so uh so
people will have questions sometimes
we'll just have to say like sorry we
actually wait a minute I did do some
shredding uh but I did that in part one
where I don't uh wasn't allowed to
capture any footage uh so uh yeah you
know the whole uh great Sky Island which
we're now allowed to talk about uh that
one I was able to shred some but not the
most efficient way of doing it it's a
lot of you know
like I think we're gonna get to it uh
eventually as we discussed yeah someone
asks uh that that one I'm assuming is
for you're free to talk about is what
did you think about the performance did
you encounter any frame drops lag
anything noticeable where you where you
were just like wow this really is
stretching the limits of the switch
I'm not sure if this was the final build
uh of the game we know the game has gone
gold uh but I have to say that yes there
was some performance drops uh both when
it came to frame rate uh I don't think
it wasn't popping as well I noticed like
the draw distances has always been an
issue on the switch yeah and I think
this game is literally pushing the the
limits for for the system I think
this is the game that's going to either
make or break the switch on how we
remember it yeah so yeah
okay so but overall it didn't hamper The
Experience itself the it was still
enjoyable enough
yeah and your first playthrough you
don't really pay attention as much to
slow down unless it really jugs down to
below 20 frames and I felt like yeah
maybe it dropped down to 25 at times uh
but nothing more dramatic than that okay
at least not yet
so uh how was your uh how was the trip
itself did you uh
did you all do it in all in one day or
did you stay in Germany for a day unlike
zeltic I flew in on Monday and had my
session in early in the morning or right
after breakfast on Tuesday
so what happened was that I had my
flight from Norway and uh yeah we just
got to the hotel uh which was pretty
much right next to Nintendo of Europe's
headquarters because the whole demo was
not taking place uh in our local office
it took place in the central office that
was also the case for the UK people who
usually have their previous at home so
it's clear that uh Nintendo and I bet
the Zelda team wanted to keep everything
on the wraps within the buildings that
they know are secure and where they have
their people to control
yeah I understand that that's why I
wasn't invited because I'm Dutch
we uh we don't get much attention here
too small we're too small of a country
even though you have a local don't you
have a written
it doesn't touch doesn't Dutch have like
a localization of Tears of the Kingdom I
don't mean yeah voice because that's
very limited but you have text I think
yes yes we do have uh localization in
terms of text not voice
so but that's enough because most Dutch
people they speak English very well
so it's pretty much a second language
here
um yeah it's mainly for children I guess
yeah
so uh of course the most important thing
right off the bat is
um I was right about the batteries
oh yeah you were definitely right about
the batteries
um
I felt like uh I feel like this whole uh
concept of vehicles of batteries and so
on it's it's very clearly that they are
following the Industrial Revolution and
also modern day uh obsession with
electric cars you know with their
batteries I think maybe Tesla cars or
some sort of inspiration
yeah
well I'm just I'm just glad my theory at
least aged well because it was it was
kind of a guess of course the yeah I
didn't play the demo by the way uh in
case anyone is wondering uh I haven't
I've had no special privileges when it
comes to this game at all which is fine
by the way I'm uh I'm not really
interested in working with Nintendo in
that way but Conrad has been
working with them in the past so clearly
they would invite him to something like
this and obviously Celtic is the biggest
Zelda YouTuber out there so exactly it
makes total sense
if I can add a word about this is that
the thing about Nintendo is that they
operate mainly with uh outlets and
content creators that cover more than
just one franchise uh I think they did
an exception for Celtic who's just
covering Zelda but otherwise you need to
have like a history with them uh
reviewing multiple franchises whether
that be Pokemon whether that be Animal
Crossings platoon Mario and and so on
[Music]
yeah that makes sense so let's get into
some specifics uh like things just in
the game that we uh first of all one
thing I've been curious about since the
very beginning can you talk about the
towers a little bit like what they uh
when they talk about their existence I
can't really talk about what they do
does unfortunately uh I can just say it
was at the enemy camp it was one of the
objectives and it does something that's
all I can say uh it's definitely uh a
construction that was placed there
uh by the Chica
and it's very provisional because of the
yeah you use wood instead of the solid
material that the Chica Towers had in uh
in uh
breath of the wild but it's clear that
it's probably not the only type of uh of
chica Tower so that's what I'm going to
say okay cool and so the uh game the
gameplay demo itself from what I
understand it was mostly confined to the
the new great plateau in the sky so
basically the the the one you see right
now the one uh aunuma was also exploring
and some very very restricted like
restrictive parts of the surface right
like near the great plateau
yeah I think we were having pretty much
a circle surrounding that enemy camp on
the surface where we could do some
experimenting uh try a little bit of
fusing try a little bit of ultra hand uh
vehicle building uh plus uh see how we
could attack this Camp from different
angles perspectives and tools which is
the whole idea of Tears where uh in
breath of the wild you were sort of
limited to either rush in the main gate
or Pro Climb your way and try to sneak
in a different way or alternatively if
uh the possibility was there use
revolving scale but now they're just so
many different options like you can
literally fly in from a direction and
then ambush from above
so it takes breath of the wild and then
just adds to it like this game overall
just feels like uh everything you could
have thought of I wish this was possible
in breath of the wild is there and tears
of the Kingdom apart from one key thing
though which is on the water exploration
at least for now yeah we're gonna have
to see uh we're gonna have to find out
if that's gonna be a a thing obviously
that will wasn't shown in the in the
demo but that's the thing they they also
didn't show any underground and we know
there is a underground that's pretty
much confirmed from all the the footage
we have now but
it's clear that they wanted you to
experience the vehicle crafting the like
I said just be creative that that scene
because that's the big new addition to
this game right it's uh it's what makes
it makes it stand out from breath of the
wild It's Not Just Breath of the wild
but bigger but it's also doing all this
weird stuff with vehicles and crafting
and combining all kinds of weapons and
tools and uh let me quickly switch to
Celtics footage in the meantime because
then we have some Mix-Ups I would say
that uh this uh vehicle system is the
final evolution of that started with
Epona back in uh Ocarina of Time almost
25 years ago where we've went from being
able to travel on uh only on foot in the
early Zelda games uh and maybe have a
cuckoo transport us from place to place
uh suddenly with opponent we could get
quicker and faster through Hyrule Field
and certain other limited locations but
now it just feels like we have broken
all sort of boundaries that you can have
yeah all right I got a message from
Austin John here
these this man is connected
uh from what I've on from what I
understand there could definitely be
dungeons but they're they were not
allowed to
seek them out or go inside them so we're
gonna have to wait for that one but the
clearly they want to keep that part of
the game a surprise
um
someone says can you fly Vehicles into
enemies I'm sure you can absolutely I I
even killed uh a bird so if I can
interact with the wildlife that means I
can also interact the same way I guess
with uh with enemies you kill the bird
by flying your vehicle into it yeah you
can you can see that when I was trying
to land there was a bird there about oh
and I was just like oh no in the back oh
poor poor bird did you see the uh I'm
not gonna show it but did you see the
footage from igen they did the meat
Arrow yeah oh I did that as well yeah
you did yeah I did that was one of the
first things I was just like no I need
to do the meme I need to do the meme
yeah good good call
that became such a joke for for people
so obviously you want to immediately try
it did you see what kind of effect it
had or
it's mostly a distraction uh but it also
works as uh well if you just fire it
straight off uh at the enemy it's still
gonna deal some damage but it's not
really efficient it's mostly there as a
distraction
ah okay
all right
um so you know the bananas with
um with the yiga clan back in uh breath
of the wild it's pretty much the same
thing where you could just sneak strike
them in um in the eagle Clan Hideout
yeah oh yeah yeah so
um
did you
uh I I saw one section where you had
like a cooking pot and it was a zonai
technology cooking pot that is that like
a portable
like yes it's a device uh that is like
you in Norway we have something called
one time Grill so I would call or call
it the equivalent of that uh because you
can only cook one uh dish on it uh but
so it's not something you can
abuse in that sense
[Music]
okay
but it is handy because at least you
don't have to worry about a cooking pot
being
in the vicinity because sometimes they
were there and breath of the wild
sometimes they weren't and then you had
to
go somewhere to to actually be able to
cook
wow Celtic shows a lot of footage from
the al-numas uh presentation also yeah
but there we go there was no other way
to show the a great uh the the sky
island section you know the one with
the area where amnuma was exploring like
there's just so much more there that
um yeah it just I wish we could have
shown it but it's understandable they
don't want to have it leaked you know
yeah are you allowed to to say the name
of that tutorial island or is that also
oh yeah I think there's all together
mentioned it in in his tutorial uh in in
the video so uh
it's what was it called the Great sky
island or something yep that's not sure
what it is instead of it's a great
Plateau
it just makes sense because it's
probably one of the biggest well it's
it's a big chunk of land floating in the
sky uh and uh the reason why it is there
of course remains a mystery we didn't
learn any story details so um yeah
that's true yeah oh medi33 is here he
says I was expecting the map will show
different layers underground will be the
third layer uh probably I would expect
that that that will be the case but the
the demo that they were playing was like
heavily restricted it's clear that it
was built
specifically for this you know this
demonstration
so they had very specific gear and I
think
because from what from what I was able
to understand from Celtic is that they
had like two different save files one
where you're on the island the the
tutorial Island and the second one is
what you see here where it's like down
on the surface and you have like four
batteries and you have you they just
gave you like you have more heart so
that it's like a mid game thing so you
can
just do your thing because obviously if
you don't have many batteries you won't
be able to go very far with these
vehicles so
they wanted to give them something to to
work with
yeah I would say so as well it's um
it's clear that they want you to fight
zonai constructs because we were in
breath of the wild a lot of people were
avoiding fighting enemies because of the
weapon durability system yes but while
here you get a very you get a dual
reward you get whatever is attached to
their heads uh and you get uh the zonai
charge which can be used to uh on those
gotcha machines that you probably saw in
a number of the previews yeah yeah that
looks very interesting if if you're
lucky you get what you want if not then
pull again that's how gacha works right
yeah but like it's not obviously without
actually paying real money so you're
paying with zodiac charges instead of uh
rupees as far as I can tell uh takers
thank you for the Super Chat the world
looks Serene when does the upheaval
happen well that's something we don't
know uh the the the demonstration was
completely without any story so they
gave them as little context as possible
this was purely to just play around
but what do you think Conrad when when
do you think the upheaval will take
place this is obviously just speculating
this is already how don't you think it
feel like it's happening the moment uh
the game starts like the moment The Sky
Islands become visible the moment link
ends up in the sky it seems that way
yeah because
it does it does say that the obviously
the great sky island is going to be the
first place you explore so I would
imagine there's just a cut scene where
we see the whole thing where Zelda falls
down and then Ganondorf escapes from
that underground cave and
then the upheaval starts that's how I I
would imagine it how else would the
islands be there for link to be on that
tutorial Island
so it's probably going to be a very very
early
story thing
in fact I think a lot of stuff that's
all been kind of like uh you know kept
Under Wraps a lot of that will present
itself very early in the game
uh let's see
is it 1080p it's probably just gonna be
what what how does this switch's
resolution work again Conrad isn't it
like upscale 1080p
when docked
hello you still there yep oh yeah I'm
still here uh when it's unlocked uh we
didn't get to play undocked
unfortunately we only played with a Pro
Controller on a docked system uh
Nintendo made it pretty clear there but
like the switch is not like real 1080p
actually right it's like upscaled or
something
yeah I think so
yeah something like that
but
yeah 900p yeah it's 900p and obviously
will be upskilled when you play on a
1080p monitor
uh
let's see
I'm just skimming through the comments
real quick
see if there's anything
um
the towers on the ground are called
Skyview Towers
that's very fitting Sky View
call back to Skyward Sword oh yeah here
you can see the gotcha stuff
where it's like so is it to your
knowledge is it it is just random so you
put charges in there and it just gives
you some random zonai stuff
which yeah it seems like it depends on
what uh like it can give you different
stuff it's just like a gacha machine
where you have you see on on the front
of the machine you see oh you can get
these things and then oh I want that
thing but you're not guaranteed you're
gonna pull that thing so there's that
and do they deplete where after usage
because I think I saw someone putting a
rocket to their shield and then using it
but after the uh after that the rocket
is gone
yeah uh the thing about the Rockets is
that they are uh consumables pretty much
uh that as soon as you've activated them
they uh
kick a punch and then they burn out very
quickly they burn out so okay yeah does
it depend on how much battery you have
no because these burn out immediately
they just burn out okay so they also
used a little bit of battery but they
also just disappear after I think like
5 to 10 seconds some something like that
okay so it's not like the uh fans where
it charges back up again
after no no it's not
wow the the hot air balloon stuff is
really cool to me it just takes you up
there and it just starts depleting your
uh your battery
yep so I guess everybody uh sorry go
ahead oh it's uh the funny the funny
thing that depleted is the fire emitter
you know the flamethrower that's the one
that uses the battery not the air
balloon itself yeah so there is Crystal
engineering involved and I really like
that you have to like go step one two
three and then then you can take off you
know
yeah I like the map by the way the
I think the fact that you do see two
layers here there's gonna be a third one
for sure but yeah that's that's probably
why we haven't seen uh even in the
commercial that uh Nintendo of America
just published
uh there was a map there uh well not a
map like the underground area we saw the
coordinates it's very deep on the ground
but uh there was no map so they did that
on purpose ah
okay okay uh
uh daenerism says the tower on this
great sky island is called
Temple of Time as seen on the sky map
oh really that is very interesting
so it's like the Zona equivalent of the
Temple of Time
more evidence that there is time travel
because I I thought that was kind of
like the everybody agreed that there is
time travel in the game now but
apparently there's still a couple of
people are
like I know Dr Wiley is still on the
fence about it he's still like I don't
know it could just be a different
dimension or she's just somewhere like
running around Hyrule
you know
yeah
also I mean like I made a very uh clear
point about the fact that every new
Zelda game that takes place in Hyrule uh
needs to have a new Princess Zelda uh
it's it's a rule that has been unbroken
uh to this day yeah so uh I I think
that's also why this is time travel
because this is the same Zelda
so then you need a different zeld
yeah
uh let's see oh the
very curious about the travel Medallion
are you allowed to talk about that
uh the travel Medallion yeah I can talk
about it it was not in in the Embargo so
you you can just place a travel Point
anywhere you want like one of them and
then as soon as you place another one it
overrides the other one so is that how
it works
yeah it's pretty much the same thing as
you had in uh breath of the walls DLC uh
where you place it one place it takes
you back to that place if you move that
the travel Medallion you know to a
different location the previous one just
uh disappears so it's a little bit like
a soft safe State it's a little right
before you make a big jump you can
decide to be like I'll just place
a travel spot here in case I fall down
yeah uh it's it's uh it's a tool that
they probably realize that oh wait a
minute we're working and in the sky what
if the person runs out of stamina while
trying to get that next Sky Island does
you have to go all the way back to then
go up up again yeah uh I think that
that's the intention
yeah we sell the two ways we're all
friends that's true well most most of us
are like the we all talk to each other
and share information and
appear on each in each other's videos
and podcasts and everything so it's a
great community in that regard like very
there's a it doesn't feel like there's
any competition because everyone
everyone is just doing their thing and
helping each other out
it's really fun
uh so let's see
um what is another thing that we can
discuss oh yeah the combining stuff to
your shield and stuff that looks really
fun did you get to experiment with that
a lot like putting stuff on your shoe
putting stuff on your arrows on your
shields on your uh on your weapons like
was that fun to experiment with oh yeah
that's a lot of fun like you realize oh
my God this giant thing can now fit on
my shield or on top of my rusted sword
yeah diffusing defusing really is a game
changer and uh the fact that there's
just so many things you can put a crate
on the shield you can put an explosive
barrel uh and the effect being that they
get blown not you which from a physics
perspective should not make any sense
whatsoever but this is that Shield is
like really powerful
yeah but like the
what would I say the blast area would
still kill you because come on The
Shield is very small yeah it would at
least break your arm and it maybe if you
hide your face behind the shield it
would work but uh that's the the
flamethrower putting that that one is
also is that the same deal by the way
when you uh put a flamethrower on your
Shield does it just
disappear after a while after it's done
uh no it's more that you have to
recharge it that's all okay that's an
item that you can fuse to your Shield
just like we saw back in 2021 uh it's
not very efficient though uh it's just
like it just keeps your enemy ignited
that's all uh but it's more useful for
stuff like you know air hot air balloons
and
maybe just fooling around a little bit
you know because you don't need it
suddenly a fire like you could easily
run out of fire items weapons uh arrows
and so on in in breath of the wild or
with this item you have something that
you well you can light a fire which is
sort of him which is important in
certain situations where you have to
solve uh puzzles especially the one um
where we saw uh that one coric puzzle
that was hidden beneath a set of leaves
that you have to burn up first yeah yeah
oh that's why I thought it disappeared
he just cut to a different part of the
footage and then the the zonai dragon
flamethrower thing was gone so that's
why I was a bit confused but uh so you
get to keep that it's not like the
Rockets
no it's uh like the plane for example uh
the Glide uh
zonai Stone glider or a bird glider or
whatever you want to call it uh that one
if you use it for too long they
obviously it just disappears because
they don't want you to cross the entire
map
because with the right engines and
enough batteries you will do that on
that thing because the speed is if you
put three or four engines yeah you're
gonna cross them up in like 10-15
minutes top
so that's why there's a limitation of I
think it's around one to two minutes uh
in in total that's at least what I
noticed because you can stack those
extra batteries and that way you can
just fly
for as long as you want even if you find
circles it's gonna
deactivate eventually and then you have
the paraglides so in this demo it was
never revealed or shown how you upgrade
your vials on your hip right that that's
never shown absolutely no well uh we saw
that temporary upgrade the yellow
battery icon with my consuming uh the
Zone I charge
yeah so it works like the yellow Hearts
do you just add a little extra charge to
uh but it's like temporary once it
drains it's it's gone
yep yeah
that that makes sense
So eventually we're gonna have eight of
those vials you can go really far then
yeah so you're not going to be really
limited and when you add those extra
batteries on top of there uh then yeah
you can go really far and that's why it
didn't the flying plane has limitations
because otherwise you could go literally
everywhere you want it because yeah the
thing with the plane is that you can go
up you can gun that you can go in
circles and have full maneuverability
you know yeah so let's talk for a sec
about recall did you use that a lot
during your gameplay
yeah Rico has uh both offensive and
puzzle solving uh abilities and also
it's a way of saving your skin if you
managed to mess up
can you recall enemies or just objects
right now uh only objects it must be
some specific objects that have also uh
moved uh in a specific Direction like uh
you can't recall for example uh zonai
items yeah I just saw my rocket yeah
yeah you can't you can't do that good
timing um so there are limitations there
are limitations to the powers and I
think it's it's uh good because
otherwise this game would just be broken
yeah plus uh maybe just like stasis you
will be able to upgrade
um recall at some point and you will be
able to reverse enemies for example but
we'll we'll just have to wait and see
that's all that's all conjecture of
course
um so the area that you were allowed to
explore on the surface that was the only
area on the surface you were allowed to
like that enemy encampment
you were not yeah we were not really
allowed to go beyond that area like
some try to go back to the gray plateau
and we got a clear message after that
you're not allowed to show any footage
from the great plateau
uh because obviously a lot has changed
and uh everyone is curious as what has
happened to this previous starting area
so that's probably why they are guarding
that place yeah well it makes sense
unintended yeah
well it makes sense for them to do it
that way because like I said clearly
this this demonstration this demo was
meant to just be like have some fun fool
around with the new mechanics but they
don't want you to
discover too much in terms of story so
there were no cutscenes there were no
like characters Beyond maybe koroks that
you talk to that share any any specific
lore or I think uh
zelticos also confirmed that it's like
there's nothing Story related
here it's just all gameplay
experimentation
technically speaking there were a few
things that are Story related but which
we're not allowed to talk about or show
uh there are certain
items that were in the inventory so they
were like they were rare restrictions in
the menus of what we could see and I
decided to just be safe because I didn't
want to spoil too much about the map I
didn't want to spoil too much about uh
different items for me uh it was all
about just showing you the basic
possibilities that the development team
has given us and not experiment too much
because I think that is something that
everyone should do on their own because
by seeing this being done by one person
you are gonna be on show you probably
just going to replicate what that person
did well this game it's clear that the
team wanted you to see the possibility
and then create something of your own
imagination
yeah and Tackle like certain issues in
your own creative way yeah like oh I
want to reach that Island I can do so
many there's many different ways I could
do that and I'm sure we haven't even
seen like two percent of the crazy stuff
that we will be able to build because we
already saw in the trailer like he built
some sort of Mech out of a giant Stone
slabby attached arms to it and stuff but
yeah you can build tanks and
obviously that they will have a lot more
in store for us and I'm very excited by
by that because everything that was is
being shown right now that's all
hand-picked by Nintendo like this is
okay but don't go beyond this because
you know it makes sense people need to
be surprised
um which is also like you said why they
didn't allow you to go to the plateau or
any other like location that's story
that would be in any way significant in
terms of story
this was all about the gameplay
um taker says King Richard the goat the
goat-hearted according to Bandit
yeah I'm very happy to see that Richard
now became the the go-to name
what once we do uh get to talk about or
show what the real name is it's gonna be
hard to go go back to uh I I just want
to keep calling him Richard from now on
just to it just became the the standard
now so oh I just call him dragon that
Dragon Dad so we have goat man Dragon
Dead uh dad and we have Richard so this
guy's gonna go by many many pseudonyms
uh at least there's only a little over
two weeks left
yeah yeah that's a
it's crazy isn't it hasn't it like how
does that feel for you uh because we've
been on this journey for well you've
been on this journey way longer than I
have but so funny story I started
editing for Conrad right after the 2019
reveal trailer so that first time the
that breath well two as it was still
being called back then when it was
revealed
like my I think that was your one of
your very very first videos after that
that was Ganondorf and the zonai it was
the first big uh
uh theory yes yeah it was the collab
with Nintendo by crisis yes where we
went over Ganondorf and the tie to the
zonai I would say a lot of the stuff we
brought up there actually was
pretty good I would say it was just a
question what Arizona are alive or not
but
nothing so far has indicated that the
Zona are alive in the present at least
yeah well that's gonna be a very
interesting part of this story to find
out uh like are the zonai in this game
or is it just the technology they left
they left behind or maybe we only get to
see this own eye in the in the past when
we view it from Zelda's perspective so
yeah that's a that's a mystery I'm very
very excited to delve into very excited
about
um so let me see JW 95 says what is the
huge tower on the great Sky Island be
wait what does the huge tower on the
great Sky Island being called Temple of
Time indicate especially with recall
uh linked to time
well of course we don't know for sure
right now but I'm I am pretty sure
that's that same room where we see Zelda
standing in the final trailer where you
see those two wheels that are spinning
uh I think that's just like a Zona
equivalent of a Temple of Time like they
may have had their own version of the
Temple of time because the Temple of
Time has been through many iterations
including versions that are completely
unrelated to the Temple of Time from
Ocarina of Time for example because the
the Temple of Time In Skyward Sword had
nothing to do with the
later incarnations of the or the later
iterations I should say of the Temple of
time so
yeah this just might just be yet another
Temple of Time uh a different one from a
different culture and uh since time
travel was pretty much confirmed to be
in the Well it's not
it's hard to say confirmed but it's very
very very very very likely that there is
time travel maybe not like for Link Link
might not do the same thing he did in
Ocarina of Time where he's just
constantly flipping between two
timelines or two time periods but Zelda
for sure seems to be in the past so
whether that's what what that means and
how we will experience that through
gameplay if at all that's
you know that's uh that's all
speculation at this point
um
let's see if I can find anything in your
footage that's interesting to talk about
so uh did they allow you to
solve puzzles
yes it did allow us to do some simple
puzzles
like the way the sky islands are
designed is that they are
a lot like the Overworld puzzles that
you see in on the surface in in breath
of the wild where there's a challenge
you have to overcome it uh there oh look
at the head here there's a gap and then
you gradually make
your way through the archipelago uh of
uh of the sky islands because you go
from one Island to another until you
finally reach the Walnut
you actually want to reach because of uh
because of the objective
yeah so you were allowed to visit quite
a few different Sky Islands right
uh a couple of them yeah uh but it was a
smaller group of islands compared to
some of the bigger ones we've seen I saw
some there on the horizon but I knew
that with the time we had and with uh
even with the items we had there was no
way you would get there and besides long
before you go got there there were guys
sitting next to you
thank you go
you're funny though like there's like a
police officer sitting next to you being
like
yep that's uh that's very so if you if
he even gets a hint that you are trying
to fly towards Jairo Castle he would
just be like nope
turn back
the rule was actually pretty uh
strict I would say because the moment
you you went to the sky island section
you were not allowed to go back to the
surface because they knew that you had
left that area uh that was safe to show
off the surface so if you went down they
said okay you cannot use this footage
and we're going straight back to the
travel Medallion location
that's why they use the travel Medallion
yeah
well
at least they are being protective of it
because yep it's gonna get harder and
harder for people to avoid spoilers so
if they allow you to use that kind of
footage
it will start circulating very quickly
so this is their way of making sure that
the creators who did because they were
allowed to record their own footage
using the capture card by the way that's
how they got all this footage
but if there's like a section that they
recorded where they're like I'm just
gonna you know quickly sneakily take a
look at something on the surface and
then I can later reference that they
will just shut that down and be like
nope you cannot show that
from what I understand the the Embargo
is quite
uh
well I wouldn't say strict but it's like
very
uh detailed it's specific I would say uh
not very specific like there's actually
quite a lot we were allowed to show but
the question is how much do you want to
show we're two weeks away from the
release of the game and my thought about
this was okay we haven't seen much of
the sky islands maneuverability from
place to place so I would just rather
focus on that instead of doing crazy
gameplay stuff because by doing that I
feel like I spoiled one of the biggest
elements of discovery that is present in
uh in this game
like we had to get to that objective no
matter what but
um you can just you can do crazy stuff
but the thing but the thing is
one it takes time to set it up and
second is that
I don't want to take that away from you
yeah because when you have seen these
mechanics once uh they are not going to
be a first experience for you anymore
yeah and I think we are now so close to
release that there it's no longer any
use to come up with like huge story
predictions or like uh big theories like
my last theory about the eighth heroine
that's that's it until release I will
maybe do some smaller videos just some
little
uh like maybe 10 little details or you
know those types of videos but I'm for
me this this was it I'm not I'm no
longer gonna do like a huge story uh
because first of all I wouldn't even be
able to make that that just takes too
much time to to create at least for me
my videos tend to be take around two
weeks to produce
um
but yeah I think
at this point it's better to leave that
part alone
and just focus on how much fun this game
is going to be and then everybody
like once the game is out and it's been
out for like a few weeks and most people
have are starting to get to the end game
that's when we can start you know
talking about the secrets and the story
and mm-hmm
uh let me quickly see because we had a
Super Chat chab see says it's just DLC
that's that that's my best friend one of
my best friends by the way he's not
being serious
it's called Sarah costume guys I'm sure
there's gonna be people who see this
specific gameplay demonstration and say
like yeah it's still just Islands above
Hyrule but keep in mind that this was a
very custom build where they were not
allowed to go anywhere practically
um let's see it's still a lot of fun
though
yeah well that's what I think that's
what their goal was with the with this
is just to show people how much fun it's
going to be to play
yeah and it's not about proving to you
that this game is going to be awesome
because the final trailer already did
that
the final trailer got us all pumped up
and I think most people who were on the
fence are now off the fence and into the
hype Camp so uh Rin for the win says how
long will you guys wait to point uh to
post spoiler content on tears of the
Kingdom I want to take my time enjoying
the first playthrough of the game but
I'm wondering about how long I should
avoid spoilers at my own risk well I
would definitely suggest not like
like if you're gonna play the game
don't look up anything related to the
story
obviously there's always gonna be
creators who will be dicks and they will
post spoilery stuff in their thumbnails
so either you're able to release
literally on the day of the release uh
clearly those channels like beard bear
and
professional hasn't posted anything in
seven months but yeah okay if there's a
moment for a comeback oh you know when
it's gonna be yeah but like those types
of people will for sure upload the whole
movie the whole game but like in a movie
format with all the cutscenes already
there
uh they're gonna post that so definitely
stay away from that
like it's it's hard to say for sure
because on the one hand you you want to
kind of like talk to people about it or
show your weird Creations so
a total social media blackout is just
not viable for most people
I will probably not be present on the
internet very much during those two
weeks because I'm basically I've
reserved like two weeks for this game
yep and then after that it's content
creation time
then I will be starting to dive into
making the content but I want to be able
to play the game without that without
that work aspect in mind or else I'm not
going to be able to enjoy the game
I might take notes once in a while if I
find something interesting I can be like
oh that that will be a cool video for
the future
but yeah uh Rin I'm not too sure you
might just want to stay away from the
internet as much as possible and just
disappear into your own world
uh but once you've beaten the game once
you are Indian In the End Game or
credits roll
that's pretty much when you can start
interacting with Zelda content again
because there's got to be plenty of
mysteries I'm sure Mysteries and weird
things that are unexplainable uh
unexplained or
you know new ruins to talk about
lore maybe dungeon lore if there are
like big dungeons
so
yeah uh
thank you
so much
uh if you had a question just
let me know uh Nason says
what's the setting slash option menu
showed off uh I need to know if the pro
HUD mode is back also were you able to
see the title screen uh well Conrad this
one's for you do you
is there any of this you are allowed to
talk about I'm not allowed to talk about
what is and the options unfortunately uh
I wish I could uh I did
go into it but it must make clear to me
that you're not allowed to show this or
talk about this
Okay cool so you better say that there's
a lot of quality of life improvements uh
in this game uh as we saw with the
cooking elements and and a lot of the
menus so uh yeah they're the things that
you know and love in breath of the wild
um minus of course the sheikaroons are
probably going to be present uh like we
saw with Celtics video that Flory Rush
is back so most of the mechanics that uh
the travel Medallion and so on even if
it was DLC is theirs so most of the
things you're used to should be there I
think they have they have learned a lot
of their lessons from
the stuff that uh edible could have been
maybe a little bit better in breath of
the wild or just me it was lacking uh at
launch you remember with um uh Japanese
audio and so on like that is something
that is basically like different uh the
original language options should be
available with the original uh with
English subtitles especially in the
anime culture where we live in yeah
so we cannot say for sure if the pro HUD
mode is back but you can like I don't
know but I I could tell you if it was in
breath while they will be in this game
too because it's they're just gonna do
more and do it better
they've had time to rethink a lot of the
stuff they did wrong in breath wild
which I'm sure they are aware of they
are aware of the criticism that the game
got
um hence why I'm 100 sure we will be
able to pet dogs
if we don't then zero out of ten that is
the big question that's the big question
like
we were not allowed to go to any of the
Stables unfortunately ah
so uh we'll have to wait for that until
um well it seems they wanted you to
avoid any place that has NPCs aside from
maybe the constructs and I think it has
to do with the fact that it's not been
fully confirmed yet that time has passed
you know uh unless because the thing is
they haven't officially said that oh
riju is older side on is older we have
seen it in the trailer yeah yeah they
have they haven't said it explicitly
that uh so in so many years have passed
since
uh the conclusion of the war of the
Calamity and blah blah blah so I I have
a feeling that we're not going to see
much of NPCs uh until at least reviews
or I don't I am gonna be honest and say
uh I have no idea what that embargo is
going to be it's probably going to be
absolutely ridiculous but I can say
straight out uh none of the Zelda tubers
that you know of uh has is going to get
a real yeah I can say a little bit about
this it's only the biggest Outlets that
are getting this game and that's because
Nintendo wants to avoid leaks yes but we
know that the source of leaks is
probably not going to be uh the people
that get a review code about the people
that somehow obtained the game early and
just yeah dump it hack the switch on the
cartridge yeah yeah yeah which will
happen because it has happened to pretty
much every game so far so if you are
very adamant about like avoiding
spoilers like about a week before
release that's when we start to get into
the danger zone that's when you will
probably start hearing stories that
people are already playing the game same
happened with age of calamity
Xenoblade pretty much every game I would
say we're pretty she could be pretty
safe until Friday
May 5th
uh we'll see if like if anything happens
before that I know Nintendo is going to
go AWOL uh mainly because uh
the main reason is that reviewers need
that Advantage like they have built this
relationship with Nintendo for years and
years on end uh and Nintendo wants them
to be the first to get their reviews and
all sorts of videos up but when the game
has leaked well people have access to it
and uh
because the game is still not out so you
are not doing this legally but uh yeah
that's the that's the danger of it so
I'm gonna be honest I hope it happens as
late as possible
yes that that would be best but we'll
we'll see at least uh because otherwise
the fruit launch date is going to be
hell literally hell
yeah I think
it's unavoidable and to some extent it's
also our own responsibilities to just
stay away
I'm sure most of you know the the usual
people like the the Zelda tubers they're
not gonna share anything they're not
gonna
put like huge spoilers on Twitter or uh
just it's more like the leaked channels
and that you know those are the type of
channels that you have to stay away from
for the time being because it's their
job to be the first at everything so if
something big drops or someone points uh
like has the game and they've secretly
been recording footage that's where it
will show up so just try to you know
stay away from Outlets that are
like famous for doing that just posting
like the same Outlets that also posted
the art book
which we all did that's the big reason
why we all did not do that because we
want to
yeah we can actually explain what was
the situation because yeah like I think
you had uploaded your collab with Celtic
a day before
uh that happened and then I had my
collab with NBC
uh uh literally two hours after the the
leak dropped uh and then we all had a
call together and we just agreed we're
not gonna cover this because one we know
that Nintendo is going to go after us
and two uh this is obviously stuff and
information that is not going to be
shared until launch day yeah which means
that it is far beyond what any of us
should know about this game at this
point at self-preservation I mean you do
not want to make an enemy out of
Nintendo out of any company because
that is just uh for most people that's
not something you can fight against uh
yeah because that case is now in court
yeah exactly it doesn't matter if you
are in the right or you feel like you're
in the right it doesn't matter there's
so many little things that they you know
that's why they have rooms full of
lawyers those types of big companies
you're not gonna
you're not going to want to risk that
because that was kind of like a bit of a
misunderstanding that people had when
when we all came out and we're like we
are not covering the the art book
people thought we were just doing that
to either
you know get a favor with Nintendo or
just because I don't know whatever
reasons people came up with but it's
just purely out of
self-preservation to protect ourselves
and not make yourself a target for that
kind of stuff
and it's not it's not like it's it's
necessary either I've been able to make
fun videos I think without
including leaks or
anything like anything of sorts
uh
oh yeah one thing that I was I was
curious about when it came to the to
your gameplay actually this is Celtics
gameplay
um
so
you're able to use Ascend in combat too
right but like the whole screen kind of
freezes up when when it does when you do
that
so you can check if you can Ascend or
not and when you arrive at the point of
arrival you can have a little look
around uh like you can't move and you
can go and strike them but before you
jump out uh you can at least do a little
reconnaissance uh and then decide okay
I'm gonna this is what I'm gonna do
because you don't know exactly what is
up there
yeah yeah
did you find any other enemies aside the
typical the goblins marblins
uh no it was mainly just possible Goblin
uh the blue uh goblins and then
um
Soldier constructs so that's also a part
of the the game that they want to keep
hidden like all the crazy enemies that
will be in the game thank you we didn't
we couldn't go and fight Leo we couldn't
go and fight uh
well a lot of all the other things we
have been teased proof well like if
there's stuff like dark nuts in the game
and read ads and obviously it's more fun
to
to run into those on your own while you
play the game
if they're going to show those now it's
not going to have the same impact like
one of my favorite
uh or well not necessarily favorite but
one of my uh biggest like uh things that
will always stick with me when it comes
to Ocarina of Time is the first time
seeing a read ad
and having no idea that they were in the
game same goes for the Wind Waker I had
no idea that we were even read ads in
that game so when I first encountered
one is like what the heck is that oh my
God
so if you're gonna show like hundreds of
different enemy enemies in a gameplay
demo like this it's not gonna have it's
going to take that away from you that
surprise
so uh
hey Trev
how you how are you doing
uh let's see
we're probably let me know when you
because obviously you you're gonna have
stuff to do yourself
uh just let me know when you uh
like if you have to go or if you have to
move on do do other stuff
oh we can keep on talking for another I
think I guess 15 minutes
yeah cool we'll do that then uh so do
you have anything planned in terms of
car content before the game launches
I'm mostly just going to cover the stuff
that Nintendo decides to publish uh I'm
not the type of guy that's gonna dwell
into leaks or anything like that because
I know that is just stuff that we we
don't we're not supposed to have access
to uh but uh I like to cover the stuff
that Nintendo brings in because
for one thing it's cool to just uh talk
about this because everything Nintendo
publishes outside of maybe the launch
trade uh trailer
uh because usually those times tend to
be spoilery but at that point you're
playing the game anyway so so no one is
going to watch that
um I think it's just nice to go over the
stuff that Nintendo has been showing
because yeah there are a few new things
in those commercials but most of them
are just a little bit extended footage
of things that have already been teased
or in the background yeah uh there and I
think that is safe
um agreed
well that's mostly what it is yeah it's
just little bit of bits of extra footage
I I guess for some people it's very but
like how we saw that the
the seven seven heroine statues like a
couple of them have disappeared
uh you know that's fun stuff to analyze
for some people
but that's about it like
I think what we saw in the final trailer
that's going to be what we have now the
rest is just mostly gonna be like little
details like in this like in this
footage alone that I'm showing in the
background like obviously you can just
you know pick out any shot here and be
like oh there so there's a malice hole
here and oh this looks uh looks to be
this and this place oh there's a malice
hole here so I'm sure there's going to
be people who will be screwed I'm gonna
be honest I don't like analyzing that
way uh because that ruins my first time
Exploration with the game
yeah some people just like doing all the
map references and uh some people there
there is clearly an uh an audience for
that but I I just like I just like point
out the things that are in front of us
and not much else
well that's why I did the video about
the eighth heroine because I don't know
if I'm right I don't know if I'm gonna
be correct about it it's just guessing
based on what I think the story might do
but I haven't done like an actual
analysis of the the Overworld for
example because
uh uh I'd first of all it takes so much
time to do that
like I've seen people who are
constructing a whole map of Hyrule right
now with every malice hole with every
Tower they've been able to spot with
every it's it's nuts the the work ethic
that goes into that is insane
but that's not really the type of
content that I enjoy doing the most I
tried it with age of Calamity doing
these like it like thorough analysis uh
videos like oh we can see in this shot
that
there's that building which means this
is that building and it looks like you
know just the typical stuff and it it
just wasn't that fun to do for me so
it's just a preference
you uh
you're are you gonna be diving into any
more Story related stuff or are you just
gonna focus on gameplay now unless
Nintendo post something I'm not gonna go
into it uh I feel like this is the Zelda
game story that I really don't want to
know any details of at least not much
more uh than we have currently I just
want to have no names I don't want to
have any sort of reference to what how
like we knew about the 10 000 years
right
uh in um yeah breath of the wild yeah
before release because of the whole
tapestry and everything uh and that's
when I I want to avoid that I don't want
to have a specific time I don't want to
have uh I don't want to see more of the
building that Zelda is in because I want
to explore it myself from the inside you
know that's that's the appeal of this
thing
that's exactly why the Zelda team has
shown nothing until after the point
where you gain the paraglider and can
return back to the surface yeah yeah
well that was opposite of the marketing
of uh breath of the Wild
well what do you mean
we're in breath of the wild they
marketed everything up to the point
where you got the paraglider yeah and I
needed a little bit outside but they
didn't show uh how you get the
paraglider from who they kept the secret
of well like it was a horribly kept
secret
but uh
because there's there wasn't much and
the same level of mystery as as we see
now because it's now it's only a dragon
dragon man a dragon dad a dragon dead
Dragon dead dragons
[Music]
yeah uh so I just I just hope they
maintain that mystery uh until we play
the game ourselves
yeah uh taker says Richard is
interesting because we kind of figured
the zonai were human more or less makes
me wonder if the zonai consists of more
than one species
well yeah I zonai could just be
referring to a group of people doesn't
necessarily mean that they were a humans
or that they were all of the same
species in fact we don't even know for
sure if the Barbarian outfit was in any
way connected to the zonai that was kind
of like the assumption that we've always
had because it kept referring to
a barbarian tribe that used to live in
Farren but Farren is pretty big and it
could just be that there was like this
Savage group of people who just lived in
the jungle there and they're getting
into the juicy stuff huh yeah yeah I
mean
it could be that Richard is a zonai
could be that that mystery woman is his
own eye we don't know that that's the
fun part of the fact that we still we've
seen so much zonai related stuff now we
know that it plays a big part in it in
this game if only for the the technology
and clearly there's going to be
backstory about them to some degree but
the fact that we still did we still
don't know what their story is and why
they disappeared and who they actually
are what they look like
the fact that we still don't know that
right now is just so so much fun to me
if we just had the answer right now it
wouldn't be as cool anymore because it
it was the biggest mystery in Rift wild
for a reason
and I'm happy they are continuing that
mystery
someone says the mystery woman is Zelda
I think she's just an ancient Zelda yeah
so I agree the Zelda of her time uh I
don't think it's highly yeah like I we
had a very interesting tweet yesterday
uh I also mentioned that during the
discussion we The Voice we held uh yeah
the voice uh and it's based on the way
it is
written uh the text is written in
Japanese so I can send it to you uh so
you have a look yeah it's like in the in
in the English version of the trailer
she says you are not alone
something like that yep but in Japanese
she says like the phrasing is different
uh what it says here is that it uses the
word
uh Sonata for you which is used usually
by very old old Japanese so it's
obviously meant to be a past uh past
tense that could also prove that that
text Zona text might be
uh Japanese kanji
the the one that we still haven't been
able to definitively translate it's just
a very old kanji um yeah so that you
don't know that would make sense if she
is like from an ancient time where
people talked differently and uh so that
that's that's cool uh Raphael says is
there still hope for playable Zelda uh I
would say so yeah yeah I don't see why
just because we've mostly been seeing
Link in action
doesn't mean they haven't hidden that
part of the game as well
because
she's in the past for a reason
and yeah it could just be cutscenes or
you're like like able to communicate
with her over like between these two
time periods like maybe if they're both
in the same geographical location
they can speak to each other or Zelda
can leave clues in the past which then
will be able to link will be able to
interact with those Clues
uh and messages and all that stuff but I
could also see that maybe she will be
playable that would be a huge surprise
if they do and I think that's what this
game is going to be all about it's going
to be all about surprises and subverting
our expectations and
so I would say it's definitely not a
it's not off the table for sure some
people were like well if if she was
playable it would have been in the final
trailer no no no no no no no no no like
people need to realize one thing what is
the title of this entire franchise it's
the Legend of Zelda If You're Gonna Make
Her playable and I mean properly
playable for the first time in The
Legend of Zelda franchise because
remember Hyrule Warriors doesn't count
it's not the Legend of Zelda yeah that
is such a it's probably the most
important moment in the entire franchise
up to that point
as the title character as the actual
Zelda yeah but I'm gonna say this if we
get any a gameplay in distance past
Hyrule I think it's gonna be as Princess
Zelda yes
yes
I also have a feeling that Link's
objective is very simple it's just to
find a way to the Past pick Zelda up and
pick up the master sword as well
yeah well it's clear that Zelda doesn't
she she needs to be there in the past
she says
it's something only I can do I
understand why I'm here now
and all the footage we've seen of link
is all in the present except maybe that
part where he's in like the throne room
and the throne room looks but that could
just it's actually very interesting
because it might be that link tries to
get to the distant past but along the
way he's gonna end up in some time
frames prior to that you know like oh
first he ends up a hundred years before
then ten thousand years before and then
finally the listen passed like that that
that's a cool possibility
uh that um
is also very spoilery which is exactly
why I'm not making a video on it
yeah it's best to leave that part uh
alone but if there if link will indulge
in in time travel I think it's only
going to be local because you do have to
understand
there we already have the map of Hyrule
we have the sky islands and we have the
underground if they also have to double
the
like the map of ancient Hyrule as well
that's gonna be that's impossible that's
impossible not in six years not in six
years yeah but that doesn't mean that
Zelda won't be playable in like very
specific sections Story related stuff uh
we have seen that picture of her with
the Chica slate for example so
is now with link you know
yeah true well maybe
she will be able to use one as well we
we don't know of course for we don't
know for sure we don't know what the
Zone I had back then that's yeah that's
the thing is we know nothing we know
nothing about this game we have seen
maybe 0.5 of the game maybe yeah the
only thing I'm pretty sure of is that
the sheikah technology was probably
inspired by the Zona technology
it's clear that they were mimicking it
um because it's so December right yeah
and it's also very clear that the Chica
didn't manage to reach the same level of
advancement
they managed to create massive machines
uh but in terms of weaponry and so on
and rules of utility not so much their
highest accomplishment as they also
called it the ancient Masterpiece was
the master cycle zero and when you look
at the monster cycle zero compared to
the stuff that was shown in the preview
now
uh yeah that's
yeah
well we're they didn't build Rockets
let's put it that way
so that's that's already uh zero one for
the Zone I yeah the only vertical uh
boundary they managed to break was for
the battlefield platform of Monk Mas
kosher yeah and maybe Palmetto
yeah as well that's true
so anything else you want to share about
the the gameplay just your overall
experience uh what your impression is of
the game just for the folks who are
watching well uh the good thing is that
we are all accustomed to breath of the
wild the only thing you need to know is
that uh you can't play this game as per
of the wall because you're gonna get
wrecked unless you have more powerful
sets and builds and everything then
maybe you will be able to do that but
the best way to play this game and in
order to get the most enjoyment from it
the first playthrough is just embrace
all the new mechanics and let your
imagination uh lose uh and take your
time literally take your time because
it's gonna take longer to complete this
game mostly because of a longer story
but the gameplay is also time consuming
uh building these things uh requires you
to stop think uh get the materials use
ultra hand and then figure out is this
gonna work like you have to think
engineering here so it's going to be a
little bit like solving uh math uh
equations yeah
and uh it's gonna take some time to come
up with the builds that you really want
to do
yeah but then again uh there are stuff
here in the game that is set up so that
yeah it's it's gonna be rewarding at the
end of the day
yeah so did you uh
did you get a the same type of wow
impression that you got back then with
ref the wild
I would say so uh mainly because of the
gameplay mechanics like if it was just
breath of the wild with Sky Islands I
would probably say I was it would have
been a little bit disappointed but now
when you have the combination of uh the
Vertical World with gameplay that
enhances the vertical experience uh you
have a sequel
like no other
yeah
I fully agree
for sure yep
uh so I guess that's uh probably gonna
be it for now
um
light simulator
so I will probably not be creating any
videos about the gameplay stuff uh
simply because I'm just not doing those
types of analysis I'm sure like guys
like Zelda lore and and stuff they're
gonna do a lot of cool stuff where they
if that's your thing like they're gonna
map a lot of things out they're gonna
spot many many things in the background
that they will be able to
exp expand upon and give their maybe
even tie it into the story in some way
uh I might do one more video where I
just talk about some lore or Mysteries
something that's easy to make
and then I'm gonna call it a day and
just play the game in two weeks and just
have fun and then you know it's been
such an incredible journey
for for all of us
and I think
we need to take the time to enjoy this
for a moment we've been
obsessing over this game for what like
uh four years almost since it's been
announced
uh I think we deserve that moment to
really enjoy this game and then we'll
get back to it the main reason is why
you should take your time with this game
is that the next Zelda game after this
it's gonna be a while it might not even
be in this decade
well I'm sure maybe we're 2D Zelda game
might come along I I really hope there's
a 2DS out again but if not
yeah it's going to be around 20 30
something around there because let's
remember we are six years away from 2029
yeah and uh they had the world to reuse
here so uh characters to reuse here
so they didn't have to do everything
from scratch but now the the next time
they will have to do everything from
scratch and yeah then we might very
easily be in the next decade yeah plus
uh I think the Zella team also deserves
a little bit of a of a break
I don't think they ever take breaks to
be honest yeah that's true uh taker says
predictions on new hardware this year
yes or no that's that one's for you
Conrad because I'm that's for me nice
um okay I'm gonna say it's
straightforward either we see it in like
the September window or it's too late uh
for it to come out this year uh and even
that is maybe a little bit too late
because the switch was revealed in
October 2016 and came up March 2017. uh
so I have a feeling that unless we see
anything revealed I don't know by July
maybe uh then it's gonna be hard for
that Hardware to come out mainly because
of how from the moment of reveal like
the demand is gonna be crazy after uh
the switch if it is let's say uh
enhanced improved like let's call the
tears of the Kingdom
the breath of the wild of of this of the
successor to switch to switch uh then we
all know what the demand is going to be
and uh the question is can Nintendo meet
that demand I also think that
the reason why I think it might not
happen this year is because I think
Nintendo wants to build up a launch
lineup similar to the one they had for
uh
um 2017 and the launch of the Nintendo
switch because everyone remembers from
that year uh breath of the wild but no
there was just so much more you had
Mario Kart 8 Deluxe which is sold better
than breath of the wild uh you had a
whole new IP called arms uh you had
Splatoon 2 which is a bit incredible in
in Japan a little bit uh Less in in the
west and then you had of course Super
Mario Odyssey and zombie Chronicles too
so I think they want to have another
year like that in the pipeline uh before
they launch the new system
well this is already shaping up to be a
pretty crazy year I haven't played it
yet but I know people are right now are
playing the new Xenoblade DLC
um I do have to say I have very very
little hope left that Metroid Prime 4
will be on the switch I think that's
gonna be for the next gen I think it
will be on both systems uh because they
promised it to build a Nintendo switch
oh no but I think I think it's going to
be that one game that is still uh that's
gonna be like a dual launcher now as old
and I was launching without new hardware
uh this time so yeah I could totally see
that
um maybe it's not going to be the launch
title of the system but it's going to be
one of those later games that oh yeah we
promised it to be both on on the switch
and the successor system uh and I know a
lot of people don't want their successor
but we have to face it the switch is
over six years old uh by the time we
reach next year it's gonna be seven uh
and I think that's a little bit of the
sweet Sports as well for console without
uh mid generation graphical upgrades on
on the TV
so um I think around this time next year
um if we haven't heard anything about
the new system then this which might
have
might struggle because it's also the
fact that we'll kind of run out of the
games that have been covered on the
switch it's our second Zelda game uh we
have had smash uh technically you can
say oh we haven't had a new Mario chord
but
let's be honest it's going to be on the
Nexus
I think the most important thing for
them is that they this time they will
set up set it up in a way where the
transition the transition itself will be
much more smooth so a lot of stuff will
just immediately be
available on the new system because
no way do I want to deal with that whole
thing like with the the we finally got
uh like golden eye and then on the new
system it's not going to be there and we
have to wait again for all those older
games to really like I'm pretty sure
they're not going to do that this time
not like with the Wii U where just a
completely complete reboot
it's uh I'm sure that the new Switch
will probably
be interchangeable like your account
will be transferable you don't have to
create another new profile and all that
kind of stuff so I just hope that will
be the case
so yep yeah
that's uh how it looks forward like I
think Nintendo has a very solid plan for
the successor and uh whenever it comes I
think we're also gonna get uh ultimate
edition of uh tears of the Kingdom
that's gonna run and look even better
than uh than it does on the switch
because yeah uh why not when you have a
such a big game and seller uh I think
that's also maybe the reason why they
decided okay uh let's get the same
people to buy the game twice uh first
now on the switch and if they want a
better version well then they can buy it
on
our next system yeah
I can see a material called zonoite
an unusual mineral that has many
purposes ancients extracted energy
wait what does it say
it looks a little bit like a car battery
right yeah it does
it does so ancient ancients used to
extract energy from these
minerals which is very interesting yeah
we might finally get the answer as to
why like where the ancient energy came
from but anyway that's speculation again
lore
um anyway yeah thanks so much for
joining me on this one and uh again I
hope you feel as lucky and privileged as
you are for having been a invited for
something so extraordinary because we I
I gave up uh gave up hope for a demo
after Pax I was like they're not doing
it this year so that must have been a
pleasant surprise from your side like I
was completely shocked when I got the
message that I didn't expect anything
the only thing I was a little bit mad of
was damn it I need to travel again I
just got back after being stranded in
the U.S and now I have to fly with the
same airline that screwed me over last
time
Lufthansa right yep yep
oh well at least it was worth it this
time yep not that packs wasn't worth the
uh the fun and meeting up like I think
if it was a relief for all of us that
the gameplay uh
Premiere came after we got back from Pax
yeah because that way we were able to
enjoy the city we were able to enjoy the
parties uh and just have fun and I think
that was the perfect uh last break
before uh yeah then Sunday started
yeah absolutely
well uh like I said thank you so much
for being here uh thank you everyone who
uh came to drop by and say hello and
listen to me and Conrad ramble I didn't
really uh do much preparation
I was just like oh we have to talk about
this tonight yeah sure okay let's do it
so but I'm happy you were able to clear
up a few things and uh I think you
managed to stay within your embargo
restrictions with this one
hadn't already mentioned in their videos
so that's done that's the good one thing
I'm I I I was I'm not sure because I'm
gonna be honest with the preview I was
actually holding back uh stuff because
uh you don't want to burn Bridges you
know it takes a long time to kill them
absolutely and uh plus that's also why
I'm only showing your footage in Celtics
footage because I know for sure you guys
kept your you know your side of the
Embargo but if I show say stuff from IGN
or someone else and it turns out later
that they actually broke embargo that
means it's on my stream now and now I'm
also a target for that kind of stuff so
um
I'm happy I was able to use your footage
in Celtics footage very thankful for
that too
um but yeah
thank you all so much for dropping by
and uh
I hope you have fun with the game you
might hear from me one last time or
maybe one more video before the game
comes out
but until then I will see you all later